I mean if you were gonna have one major
takeaway from today around your own
photography remember I said you know
you're the documentarians of your own
lives when you use your iPhone or
whatever you're using don't take two
seconds on the picture take 10 seconds
frame the picture slow down
decide what you want and take two
pictures and then there's a second part
of that and that is make sure you take
that photo you process it and you store
it someplace else because I hate to tell
you and you already know this iCloud
doesn't work you're gonna lose all of
those photos eventually you're gonna do
a backup you're gonna change phones you
have to spend the time to preserve these
memories and that's even beyond like the
cloud or Google you probably have to do
what Kevin doesn't print the book you
know eventually if it's not on paper
it's probably in trouble but if you all
take that extra second I mean how many
photos do you need of anything you just
need one photograph so just take a
little bit of time
look I've been shooting for 20 years I
just learned that lesson with my phone
which is take a few more seconds
[Music]